اقتصاد روسيا في زمن الحرب اظهر قدرتها
السريعه على التاقلمي مع المستجدات رغم
توقعات غربيه بانهيارها سريعا في ظل
عقوبات عزلتها عن العالم ما طرح التساؤل
حول كيفيه حصول ذلك
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اشارت الى ان روسيا
تحايلت على منع العديد من البضائع الغربيه
من الوصول اليها
فعلى مدى الاشهر العشره الماضيه برزت
جورجيا قناه اللوجستيه المريحه بين روسيا
والعالم الخارجي
فما تحتاجه يتدفق اليها عبر الطريق شاحنات
بطيء ومزدحم يمر في جبال القوقاز بحسب صور
نشرتها الصحيفه
كل يومين تعبر قافله من الشاحنات على طول
طريق جبلي سريع من جورجيا نحو الحدود مع
روسيا رحله تبدا عاده من تركيا وتنتهي في
البلدات والمدن الروسيه حيث يزداد الطلب
على السلع الغربيه
تضاعفا حجمه عبور البضائع بين تركيا
وروسيا ثلاث مرات خلال الاشهر السته
الاولى من العام الماضي جرى نقل الكثير
منها على الطرق الجورجيه وفقا لبحث اجره
بنك تي بي سي كابيتال الاستثماري والرائد
في جورجيا تغيير استراتيجيه روسيا لسد
حاجتها الاساسيه بالحصول على بضائع من دول
مجاوره اخرى مثل ارمينيا واذربيجان ساعد
موسكو على التغلب على العاصفه الاقتصاديه
الناجمه عن حربها على اوكرانيا وفقا
لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز التي قالت انه من
المستحيل معرفه مقدار البضائع الاوروبيه
العابره لروسيا والخادعه العقوبات الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن ظهور جورجياك حلقه من رئيسيه
في التجاره مع موسكو يوصل للضوء على ثغره
المحتمله في سياسه العقوبات الغربيه روان
حمزه العربيه